[Music]
welcome back to this special edition of
Hannity the White House announced
yesterday the president Trump will hold
a one-on-one summit with Russian
President Vladimir Putin on July 16 in
Helsinki Finland on Air Force One today
the president told reporters that he
will discuss with Putin the ongoing
situations in Syria and Ukraine election
meddling and the de-escalation of
tensions with Russia and China president
Trump's national security adviser
Ambassador John Bolton was in Moscow
earlier this week meeting with Putin and
their other Russian officials to help
prepare for this summit he also
addressed critics who believe the
meeting shouldn't happen due to the
ongoing Russia probe taking place here
in the United States take a look well I
think a lot of people have said or
implied over time that a meeting between
President Trump and President Putin
would somehow prove some nexus between
the Trump campaign and the Kremlin which
is complete nonsense for the leaders of
these two countries to me there are wide
range of issues despite the differences
between us where both the president
Truong president who didn't think they
may be able to find constructive
solutions joining us now with reaction
retired CIA senior intelligence officer
and Fox News contributor Daniel Hoffman
and former deputy assistant to President
Trump and Fox News national security
strategist Sebastian Gorka all right
good evening gentlemen
dan I'm gonna start with you you know
what's fascinating to me is that you
know since John Bolton has been the
secretary of state I mean we've had a
meeting with Kim Jong on we now have a
meeting lined up in two weeks with Putin
I mean isn't it is just amazing is it
not that we have been able to have these
sit downs when the last administration
didn't know how to meet with anybody
that that like Putin or Kim Jong on
ambassador bullit
absolutely right about the importance of
high-level diplomacy I would caution
just from my experience at CIA about
managing our expectations we have an
extraordinarily complex and challenging
relationship with Russia where few of
our interests intersect we also have
this background of Russia's nefarious
espionage operations their meddling in
our election with cyber intrusions which
ambassador bolt and in my view rightly
called an act of the war right but
there's no question that it's important
the stakes are high and that's why
diplomacy matters we will talk about the
important issues of the day including
arms control the START treaty is due to
expire in February 2021 we might want to
talk about extending it there's Ukraine
and Syria not to mention the traditional
issues of counterterrorism
counter-proliferation and fighting
organized crime together all right
Sebastian Gorka let's talk about Ukraine
you know the pro-russian separatists and
everything going on in Ukraine that
Barack Obama did nothing about I mean
what leverage do we have with Russia to
be able to get them to forget about
coming to the table they're already at
the table but how do we leverage them
well Russia is in a world of hurt right
now if you look at every single
significant policy decision the
president has taken in the last year and
a half judge which has any impact on
Russia they have been hurt whether it is
unleashing fracking in the unwire
whether it's getting NATO nations
finally to pay the 2% of their defence
budgets or whether it's arming the
Ukrainians we have a lot of leverage
this is a country that is in a death
spiral 600,000 Russians die every year
more than our born the average mortality
of a Russian male is under 60 so there's
all kinds of things where it's economic
diplomatic that we can leverage but the
big problem is this is a this is a
nation run by a former KGB officer and
into the kinds of people that Daniel had
was dodging in Moscow for many years
this is not your average country all
right Daniel you're shaking your head
keep that so I'm nodding it's the best
in Cork dr. Gork has a hundred percent
right about that all right but then but
then
what do we have to offer them well it
you know I think dr. Gorka was right
about the leverage in Ukraine what
scares Lattimer Putin is democracy
that's an existential threat to his
regime security having a country on his
border with a large number of ethnic
Russians and russian-speaking population
like Ukraine which is in growing in its
relationship with the European Union and
with NATO and has just received tomahawk
anti-tank weapons javelin anti-tank
weapons from the United States I think
we need to double down on our support to
Ukraine I'd like to see the president
publicly make a statement a commitment
to Ukraine's territorial integrity and
independence at the summit
I think harder one for us is going to be
Syria where this week Russia launched
attacks in southwestern Syria that
resulted in the deaths of lots of
civilians they broke the truce that was
agreed to a year ago I think that was a
truce designed to allow Assad to go
focus on other areas in Syria like
Damascus Russia's allies are his Bala
and Iran I'm not sure I see us breaking
through there with any sort of a
resolution well does does Russia
dr. Gorka have any kind of incentive to
get out of Syria what does it benefit
Russia to be in Syria well look Russia
has to be understood is different from
other countries this isn't Belgium this
isn't Canada
I always label Russia as an anti status
quo actor they meddle in other people's
business they destabilize regions to
profit from that instability however
they're in trouble in Syria remember
secretary Manus has said that US forces
have killed over 200 Russian mercenaries
in Syria it's not going well it doesn't
play well at home they want relevance
Putin wants to demonstrate relevance and
he knows with Donald Trump
this is a very very different president
and when they have this meeting and I
just have a few seconds left what do you
think we're gonna come out with but I
think we're going I want to thank you
both for being with us tonight thank you
dr. Gorka and thank you so much Dan
Hoffman